When we arrived there, after a month of traveling across the ice,
and we'd got to them, but then I was not allowed to photograph them.
They said, "You cannot photograph us. You have to wait.
You have to wait until you get to know us. You have to wait until you understand us.
You have to wait until you see how we interact with one another."
And only then, it was many, many weeks later, I saw a respect.
They had zero judgment.
They observed one another, from the youth, from the middle aged to the old.
They need each other.
The children need to chew the meat all day
because the adults don't have any teeth,
but at the same time, the children take the old aged people out
to the toilet because they're infirm,
so there's this fantastic community of respect.
And they adore and admire one another, and they truly taught me
what beauty was.
(Applause)
Now I'm going to ask for a little bit of audience interaction.
This is extremely important for the end of my talk.
If you could look at somebody left to the right of you,
and I want you to observe them,
and I want you to give them a compliment. This is very important.
Now, it may be their nose or their hair or even their aura, I don't mind,
but please look at each other, give them a compliment.
You have to be quick, because I'm running out of time.
And you have to remember it.
Okay, thank you, thank you, thank you, you've given each other compliments.
Hold that compliment very, very tightly. Hold it for later.
And the last thing, it was extraordinarily profound,
and it happened only two weeks ago. Two weeks ago I went back to the Himba.
Now, the Himba live in northern Namibia on the border of Angola,
and I'd been there a few times before,
and I'd gone back to present this book I'd made,
to show them the pictures, to get into a discussion with them,
to say, "This is how I saw you. This is how I love you.
This is how I respect you. What do you think? Am I right? Am I wrong?"
So I wanted this debate. It was very, very, very emotional,
and one night we were sitting around the campfire,
and I have to be honest, I think I'd had a little bit too much to drink,
and I was sort of sitting under the stars going, "This is great,
you've seen my pictures, we love each other." (Laughter)
And I'm a little bit slow,
and I looked around me, and I said,
I thought, maybe, the fence is missing.
Wasn't there a fence here last time I came?
You know, this big protective fence around the village,
and they sort of looked at me and go, "Yeah, chief die."
And I thought, okay, chief dying, right, you know,
look up at the stars again, look at the campfire.
Chief die. What on Earth does chief die have to do with the fence?
"Chief die.
First we destroy, yeah? Then we reflect.
Then we rebuild. Then we respect."
And I burst out in tears, because my father had only just died
prior to this journey,
and I didn't ever acknowledge him,
I didn't ever appreciate him for the fact that I'm probably standing here today
because of him.
These people taught me that we are only who we are because of our parents
and our grandparents and our forefathers
going on and on and on before that,
and I, no matter how romantic or how idealistic I am on this journey,
I did not know that until two weeks ago.
So what's this all about?
Well, there's an image I'd like to show you,
quite a special image, and it wasn't essentially the image I wanted to choose.
I was sitting there the other day, and I have to finish on a strong image.
And somebody said, "You have to show them the picture of the Nenets. The Nenets."
I was like, yeah, but that's not my favorite picture.
She went, "No no no no no no no. It's an amazing picture.
You're in his eyes."
I said, "What do you mean I'm in his eyes? It's a picture of the Nenets."
She said, "No, look, look closely, you're in his eyes."
And when you look closely at this picture, there is a reflection of me in his eyes,
so I think perhaps he has my soul, and I'm in his soul,
and whilst these pictures look at you, I ask you to look at them.
You may not be reflected in his eyes,
but there is something extraordinarily important about these people.
I don't ultimately have the answers, as I've just shared with you,
but you must do. There must be something there.
So if you can briefly reflect on what I was discussing
about beauty and about belonging and about our ancestors and our roots,
and I need you all to stand for me, please.
(Laughter)
Now you have no excuse. It's almost lunchtime,
and this is not a standing ovation, so don't worry,
I'm not fishing for compliments.
But you were given a compliment a few minutes ago.
Now I want you to stand tall.
I want you to breathe in. This is what I say.
I'm not going to get on my knees for two weeks.
I'm not going to ask you to carry a goat,
and I know you don't have any camels.
Photography's extraordinarily powerful.
It's this language which we now all understand.
We truly do all understand it,
and we have this global digital fireplace, don't we,
but I want to share you with the world,
because you are also a tribe.
You are the TED tribe, yeah? But you have to remember that compliment.
You have to stand tall, breathe in through your nose,
and I'm going to photograph you. Okay?
I need to do a panoramic shot, so it's going to take a minute,
so you have to concentrate, okay?
Breathe in, stand tall, no laughing. Shh, breathe through your nose.
I'm going to photograph.
(Clicks)
Thank you.
(Applause)